Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
one of my favorite tools for managing Kubernetes
manifest. That is Kapitan.
It helps reduce the complexity or manage the
complexity of your Kubernetes Terraform and other deployments
and configurations.
To do that and to join me today,
I have Alessandro and Ricardo from the Kapitan
team. Hello. Hi.
Hi.
Hi, David. Thank you for having us here.
No. It's my pleasure. I really do mean
it. See this is one of my favorite
tools. I'm really glad that I'm joined by
both of you today, and we can share
that and show that to everyone that is
watching.
Shall we start briefly then with some introductions?
We'll start with Alessandro since you're first on
the screen, and then we'll move down to
Ricardo.
Yeah. So my name is Alessandro de Maria.
I'm head of SRE
at Synthes,
a company that deals with automation
in biology. So it's a it's quite a
a a relative kind of a
a field,
know, in
in this case.
And I used to work at DeepMind before,
so that's where I met Ricardo,
and we got together to work on on
Kapitan.
So at the moment, it's, I think, three
or four four years that we've open sourced
it. And I think this year, we've seen
much more interest, and we want to take
advantage of
as much as we can view on everybody
else in the community to see if we
can make it more popular and give it,
you know, better
better opportunity.
That's for me.
Cool.
Hi. I'm Ricardo. I am currently a software
engineer at Google. I think it needs no
introductions.
More specifically, Google Health.
And
be before that,
I was also a deep mind, as Alessandro
said.
And we were running
a team of SRE there, and that's when
we,
you know, had the idea to create something
like Kapitan.
And
thank you for having me here.
Awesome. Thank you very much.
Alright. So why don't we start then
and just tell people what Kapitan
is?
Do you wanna give us the slides for
that or do wanna talk about it first?
Yeah. I think the slides is a is
a good way. We try to
I think let me open, make sure that
they are open. Yes. So we try to
it, and pretty much every time it comes
out in a different from a different point
of view. I don't know if these slides
are already
visible. Yeah? They are. Please. Yeah. Yes. Perfect.
Yeah. So
Kapitani is a tool, again, that we created
in
a deep mind at the time where,
there were fewer opportunities, fewer other tools. I
think, Helm was already,
out there, but we were looking for something
slightly different,
especially because we were we had a a
very
kind of particular
setup with DeepMind Health where we were we
were working on
lots of components that we were doing doing
ourselves. So
I'll start with with this kind of slide
just to explain a little bit
what led us to to work with
to work on Kapitan.
With Helm,
sorry. With with Kubernetes,
we realized at the beginning that there were
so many resources,
so many manifests for each given workload that
we have to manage.
And, pretty much, we realized that,
a good part of those resources were, well,
ball boilerplate.
There were some application specific kind of configurations,
and and they were also, like, environment or
release specific. But pretty much, you you kept
repeating the same kind of configuration over and
over and over. And while
I think other tooling like Helm was
had the advantage of a a packaging kind
of application that were written for,
like, off the shelf kind of application. We
were looking at
we were not gonna use that anyway because
we were developing our own application. So we
looked at it in a in a different
way and from a different perspective.
And, I think the point is that we
wanted to be able to not just configure,
the one application,
but to, like, act actually
manage the full deployment, the full environment.
We wanted to make sure that if you,
if you write a
piece of configuration information
of something that you have it within your
infrastructure,
you could share it
across
many other systems. And I think probably this
is what we are going to explain today.
So
first of all, now mean, this is now
jumping to, nowadays. We have Kubernetes
resources coming from many different places. So we
have, like, a Helm charts, which is, by
by far the most popular way to get,
kind of a to get started with Kubernetes.
We have customized.
We have some controllers that sometimes, like, create
new
inject kind of configuration right into the cluster,
and many other kind of different ways that
you basically end up using every day
to,
to to get your deployment, to get to
get your infrastructure running.
With on top of that, there are new
CRDs being added every day. So it it
is really, if you look at, from a
from a user perspective, if you imagine how
many resources you have to deal with,
when using Kubernetes is just a a a
huge amount a huge number.
And so
we started to to look at, you know,
the this kind of tools. So we we
keep comparing with what's out there.
Like, the most,
known,
tools are Helm, Customize, Tanka. There are many
others. I don't want to include all of
them. But I I think pretty much what
the the reason what led that led us
to develop Kapitan, we still haven't seen, like,
an alternative for to to fill our need
is that most of these other application tend
to focus
on one component
at a time
or one application at a time and don't
have, like, the the ability to capture the
full deployments or the full setup you have
across all your infrastructure, at least not in
the way that we we we we become
used to to do.
They don't
allow to
or or promote the reuse of configuration data.
Oops.
Configuration data.
And I think, in
general, every year of these kind of components
have a slightly different kind of approach for
for some aspect of it. So the way
you deal with the secrets on Helm would
probably be different than you do it with
customized probably different than you do in Tanka.
Yeah. And in general, I think another component,
I think this is something that would become
more clear when
as we go through the presentation is that
we all these components that all these other
systems tend to
defer rendering the
produce manifest to the last stage, while we
think that managing the the compiled the rendered
version of the of the manifest is is
a is an important feature
that helps us, when we want to, review
our changes. So
and again, in general, these are all kind
of Kubernetes centric. So at the end, it's
like you have this
idea
that everything you will be
dealing with in on a day by day
kind of everything to do with Kubernetes. In
reality, we have many other
components. And this is what, I mean, gives
gives
brings back to the idea of we we
always call it a generic configuration
system. It's that the same system can be
used for Terraform,
can be used for Istio,
can be used for Spinnaker,
pipeline, can be used for Ansible, and and
for many other tools.
We've
also seen that some people are using Kapitan
for
for for generating basically
a configuration for their internal
or legacy
tools.
And we wanted to be able, from a
center point, to manage playbooks, documentation, and dashboards.
I realized
that in these slides, I'm pretty sure I
have it somewhere, but I think it's it's
in a little bit. I think I I
these are basically setting up the the kind
of understanding of what Kapitan
is and what we're trying to achieve. We're
trying to to give you a single place
from which you can manage playbooks, documentation,
dashboards,
and every systems that you have out there,
ideally.
And so, basically,
with that consideration,
we were trying to basically have that one
single thing
can control all of your infrastructure. And this
is basically what I'm trying to
to
explain, to introduce what Kapitan actually is.
Kapitan is effectively
a a tool that allows you to generate
files
to be consumed by other systems. So it
doesn't Kapitan is not a tool for Kubernetes.
It's not for Terraform. It's just something that
somehow does its job of creating configuration and
then gets out of the way.
And I
think this very generic approach has the the
the benefit
of
allowing you to
pretty much enable the same workflow and the
same kind of approach
when managing
different classes of, systems and different classes of
technologies,
which is unfortunately
where we stand right now. We don't just
deal with Kubernetes at the moment. We deal
with many other kind of systems at once.
I think this is a a stop right
here. I think I talked already enough, and
I don't know if you have already questions
regarding this. I also realized that I don't
have a view of a of a of
you on the screen, so I'll just quickly
move the
move the presentation out of the way so
I can position it somewhere else. Otherwise, I
don't get any
here you go.
Alright. Very good. Back back here. We're we're
back on the now. So thank you for
that those intro slates.
If anyone watching has questions, please feel free
to use the comment section on YouTube. Leave
a comment to us, and we'll do our
best to handle them as we go or
group them at the end depending on how
relevant they are.
Now I think what we should do is
just get started. Right? We're gonna show people
how this works, how to install it, and
how to start using it. So So we
sorry. We we I do have more slides.
I didn't want to just I I just
wanted to give you the time to to
you know, if there was some any specific
question right now.
Unless you you think we should we should
move on. But I I just wanted to
quickly explain some basic concept before we move
on. Otherwise, you you you know, up to
you what what you want to do. No.
I mean, that's what I was when I
pulled up the website there, I was literally
gonna go through the key concepts to give
the the audience a bit of a vocabulary
and what that means. Okay. We have slides,
then that's perfect. I think I think yeah.
I think we have slides with that, and
we we let's see if if we made
a if you made it clear and and
if you can help us later. So let
me go Your slides are visible. Yeah.
Here we go. Yeah. Now I I can
see myself before I was a bit blind.
Sorry for for that.
So, like, Kapitan,
first of all, comes with batteries
included. I mean, the tool itself has a
a a range of features, which we will
discover through the website as well. So first
of all, we have this concept of the
inventory that allows you to reuse values and
share configuration data across many of the systems
that we will be dealing with. So you
will be able to define the configuration for
something and reuse it in
a cup Kubernetes,
Terraform,
documentation,
and so on. So that's the the kind
of first thing.
Second,
the same inventory data that you have can
be reused through a number of very powerful
into input types. So you can use, Ginger,
JSON, it, Cadet, Helm,
or other kind of tools to
to render, to create,
templates for whatever you want to whatever your
task is.
And I think the the third important key
is that,
Kapitan handles natively,
secrets with a with a very kind of
a
very nice kind of a support for, for
secrets. And we handle the majority of secrets
back end with the the ability to easily
extend to to add more and more secret
back ends as we go. And in general,
we have a, like, a an an external
ability to fetch dependencies externally. So instance, because
we have the Helm integration,
we can fetch Helm right from the repository,
and we can now just bring it in
through through Kapitan.
So the inventory is I think it's the
it's the the one concept I wanted to
be able to explain. The inventory
is basically becomes the single source of truth
for
Kapitan.
So it's a a YAML based structure
that lets you
define configuration in different files and then merge
them together in a way that it makes
sense to you and in a way that
I think will become clear as we start
using it. I think
so sorry. Sorry, Ale. The thing another thing
we can say is that the the inventory
is
somewhat inspired
by the puppet Hira.
No. It's essentially a essentially a tree of
values
that you can refer to within your programming
of templates. So you can always
ensure that the values exist somewhere. You don't
have to have them hardcoded
in your code, but they'll belong in the
inventory. That's the idea.
So, yeah, define it once, use it multiple
times, use it across multiple targets, multiple templates.
And the
basic idea revolves around the concept of a
target, which is what what you are working
on. So your current project you're working on,
and classes, which is pieces of inventory that
you can share across different targets.
The the one new thing that we have
so if people have experience with Kapitan before
and they run away from it because they
thought it was too difficult,
the one thing that we would like to
show you today is this kind of new
approach that we have to
easily generate
configuration
straight from the inventory, which I think is
extremely powerful. And I think this is what
if we have to
do any demo or any kind of a
a way to show how to use Kapitan,
and I think that's that's what we we
will be doing today. So there is no
JSONET doc cadet at all. So if you
if you've if you've always associate associate Kapitan
to just on it, it's a a
a it now becomes clear that JSONET is
something that can power Kapitan, like Cadet or
Python,
but it's not necessarily the only way to
to experience it.
And the way to describe is like a
a a very powerful plug in where you
can define something that you want to create,
the Kapitan will generate it for you. So
we can go that in a into into
details soon, but the plan is to release
at the moment, we have a Kubernetes one,
which we will be playing with today. But
we will the plan is to release more
and more generators as we go
as we go along.
And
any I think, probably pretty much, this is
the last part. Everything else, I think we
can even go back later. But this is
basically the workflow we will see today as
we play with the Kapitan. So you will
be
editing
the configuration in Kapitan.
Usually,
we generator usually will be editing the inventory.
So every edit editing kind of a YAML
structures.
Kapitan will compile
and create
outputs for you, like output manifests.
And once that kind of review process has
finished,
you you do what you want to do
with those outputs. Most of the time is
to deploy to your environment. They can be
anything else. It can be including,
you know, like, a running script or generic
documentation and everything else. And I think with
this, I've covered the main concept. There is
a little bit more, but I think we
can, go on with the with your demo
and and
the on the website and and we can
see we can discover new things as we
go along.
Alright. Perfect. Thank you very much, Alessandro.
Yeah. I I mean, you you've covered so
much of the project there that I just
I think I'll highlight a few of the
things that that I really like about Kapitan.
The first one is just the way that
I can actually have reusable composable
artifacts by using this, and it's not a
case of, like, this hierarchical designer if I
have to inherit a whole manifest and then
be able to, like, overly tweaks in a
weird way. Like, I feel like that constraint
is removed from me, which I think is
really powerful.
The secret management's built in, I think, was
one of the reasons that I got drawn
to it in the first place, not having
to manage and deal with, you know, sealed
secrets or or SOPs and also tools and
trying to daisy chain them together
was a big one as well.
And I guess lastly, a feature that you
haven't mentioned, but I think it's really important
is that every time I say the name,
I sing El Kapitan by OPM, which I
think is is really important to having a
happy working day for me. So that's really
cool.
Now,
let's get started. Right?
We have to do that? Okay. Let's do
it. Yeah. Absolutely.
Okay. Let's see.
So this is the
Kapitan website,
and we are gonna go to the getting
started page. Or do you wanna start somewhere
else? I'll let you two guide me a
little bit here.
No. That's good.
Yep.
Overview is good.
Alright.
So we need to
get Kapitan installed.
Oh, Sam, you're have to go back and
see. So I I yeah. I think if
you if you probably the best way to
if you go back to the homepage
and if you follow the Kapitan
reference,
our reef reference repository to get started with
Kapitan,
which is in the community section,
the third,
right in the middle of your screen.
There you go. Yeah. Exactly. So I think,
because Kapitan,
basically,
it's a it's a tool that obviously requires
the, inventory to be set up, for you.
So we've done is we've created, like, an
ideal kind of a setup that you can
use to get started.
And I think this is probably the best
way for you to experience it literally
as not
as simple as cloning it and and running
Kapitan from there. So I think that's
something
that we can
Okay. Alright. We have the Kapitan templates.
Yeah.
So there is a we will go through
the you know, this kind of repository, but
pretty much you can see that
as soon as you have a terminal open
and you run Kapitan compile,
you will be able to, hopefully,
see
Kapitan downloading the latest image. So we're using
a Docker image to speed up kind of
the the process of getting started.
You can also install Kapitan yourself, but I
think Docker image is
is is the the approach Universal way.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
Yeah. So Kapitan is available through PEP as
well, isn't it? Yep. Yeah. Yes.
And and so this process that you can
see here, these are basically a example and
templates that have been compiled for you. So
from from here, we can we can carry
on and discover how to get started with
Kapitan.
Is this you want to go through the
slow walkthrough, or should I go back to
the getting started guide? What's your preference?
I think this is basically an
explanation of this repository in general.
I don't know. Perhaps we can I I
can
guide you? So if you go back to
Kapitan
reference. Yeah.
And,
if you go to the top,
of the repository
sorry. If you go just scroll up a
little bit, and there is a, just after
Kapitan reference, there is a manifest generator documentation
That could be a a good way to
to kind of get started. Mhmm.
It's it's
kind of assuming that you already know that
you need to create a target. So I
I think the the the one thing you
will discover is that we need to work
more on on getting
Kapitan,
you know, to be to be used more
easily.
But, yeah, basically, if we go here in
the repository and you
navigate through the
targets
inventory targets
folder.
Yeah. And then you can create a new
file if you want.
So create call it, like, demo dot yaml.
So he this way, we're basically
telling Kapitan we want to create a new
project. We want to work on something new.
So if you
compile compile now, if you run the the
the compile process you run before, this time
you will have to do it quite often.
So perhaps I don't know if you want
to have a,
like, a a view right right in Visual
Studio code. I think that will be
quicker.
But the the process is always like,
you edit something, you compile, and you see
what happens, basically. So it's something minor thing.
Sorry.
There is a limitation,
the moment in inventory. Your your files need
to be
a dot YAML without a without an a.
So y m l, not y
Oh. A. Oh. Yeah. Well,
that's perfect. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Go for it.
And so
you will see, hopefully,
your
Also, you have to put stuff in there.
Right?
Oh, yes. Okay. I
I just wonder what it was gonna do
with an empty YAML file. Is it just
gonna magically make it up? But I don't
know. I don't know. I'm just gonna say,
the fact that you didn't crash is already
at that time. So
So so the
the the target is is is we just
need to add a little bit of boilerplate.
So if you if you create, like, the
the top plate, if you in the the
top part, if you write classes
and you create, like, a list of classes
and the first one is common,
that's the boilerplate you need. And I think
from from then on, you can probably follow
the the rest of the documentation you have
now. So if you go back to that
document
the, you know, the the page that we
opened before with the agent yeah. This one.
So you can, I think, already start using
with with this generator?
So as I said before, the generator is,
like, something that allows you to quickly create
configuration for you. So in that case, we
will be creating a configuration for a component
called the EcoServer.
Okay. Can we then just take a moment
to maybe explain to people what a target
and a a class is in this context?
Yeah.
Yeah. So this is something I went through
in the presentation, like, briefly before. But, basically,
a target is is like your leaf file
to get to get Kapitan started. You know,
you define a target, and that will usually
be
mapping to a manifest or a number of
sorry. A namespace, a Kubernetes namespace,
or, like,
an application something you want to work on.
It can be if you're working with Kubernetes,
most likely will be all the application that
you want to stuff into a namespace.
If you're working with Terraform, it could be,
like, a project that you want to create.
So without app or correlate like, when I
think of a target, would that be, like,
my production environment? Would it be my staging
environment? Exactly. Exactly. It's
up to you, really. It's really up to
to how how you or your team work.
Some people share environments, some people share clusters,
some people share namespaces. So Yeah. It's really
your your deployable
group of stuff in a way. That's how
you should think about it. So here, we'll
call it call it namespace, but, essentially, it's
a target. That's what it is.
Yeah. Some people ask us that question. And
the thing is that
the inventory in Kapitania is so
generic, and you can reuse in whichever way
you want. Ultimately, it depends on once you
get the feel for it, you will understand
how to organize it. Sometimes it's a namespace.
Some other cases, perhaps you want to define
an application that you want to deploy to
many clusters at once. So, you know, how
how you use it,
it's up to you. Our
typical way to use it is to define
all the applications you would want to install
on a a Kubernetes namespace, which I think
is, in this case, we will be defining
a target called demo, and we will write
all the applications that we want to create
within it.
Okay. And
the classes is
still an inventory file while the target is
the first one Kapitan goes to look for.
Classes are
other YAML file that looks exactly the same,
but they they group
other kind of
configurations.
And so they're they're used for
sharing
that kind of information with the with the
target. So as you add the class, the
class will bring in all these other kind
of
values from from the files they are defined.
And ultimately, we've created, a merge to representation
of your inventory,
which will be
composed of all the classes you have imported
plus the definition you have at target level.
So one one thing that we can also
show in a minute is,
you know, this might be a bit hard
to picture
mentally how it ends up, you know, merging
everything. So you can run the inventory on
the command line. You will see it's rendered.
So you don't really have to try and
understand what will happen. You can actually see
it before you create anything.
Yeah. So now if you run Kapitan
inventory
hyphen t Oh, for that.
Yeah.
Space hyphen t and then demo, which is
your target,
you will basically
see
the
inventory that so far has been created for
the demo target you're working on. And this
is basically brought in by the common
boilerplate
kind of a class, and I use I
use that word. But, basically, it's like a
predefined set of configuration
allows you to get started with it.
Okay. From from that Try and summarize that
a little bit. Right? So I think the
targets were well explained. You know, they're they're
groups of things or targets,
like namespaces
or environments that you wish to deploy to.
Classes can be as small or as large
as you want, and they can be composed
together. So you can have loads and loads
of small classes that can be grouped together
by some sort of aggregator class allowing you
to, you know,
really get down to the nitty gritty of
small tiny classes, but then provide a single
class to deploy to your target. So Yes.
A really, really flexible and composable solution, which
I think is Yes. Yep. Is key for
people to understand.
Yeah. I I I think the key aspect
to which I I like to
to to talk about is the fact that
the class can you can name class with
the in whichever name you want, which usually
is it's helpful to map them in in
terms of business
concept or at least things that are related
to your activity. So,
if, say that you are changing a value
for
a, Java server that you want to have
no memory,
rather than just, write that kind of a
a value
in a in a values file somewhere, you
can map it as a a profiles dot
production or profiles dot high memory.
So it allows you to basically group together
values that would normally not have much meaning,
but you can you can attach some sort
of
meaning by just naming the class in in
in a way that makes sense to you.
Yeah. Although, at Java, JVM need more memory.
It's completely unheard of. So that was a
terrible example.
Terrible example.
Sorry.
Alright.
Okay. So we have our wrong folder. We
now have our demo target, which is pulling
in the common class. We can take a
look at the common class here. We can
see that it's just pulling in another class,
Kapitan common, and we've got a few parameters
that can be provided.
Yes.
Okay.
What you wanna go back to the manifest
generation step. Right? Yes. So if you now
cut and paste this first part,
so the
yep. That one.
And you will add it to the target.
Yeah.
So here
is where you start basically
adding your own custom setup to the target.
So you are add you're defining something up
in the parameters.
So classes and parameters, you will see them
replicating all the other, classes as well.
And here, what we are doing is we
are defining a special kind of a through
a special syntax. We are saying,
I want to basically create a new component.
I want to call it echo server, and
I want an to to have an image
called
like that. But this is a a beautiful
project I always use very easy to get
started like a a a web server, and
it's very easy to to to play with
it, basically. If you compile right now, you
will see a couple of things happening, and
we can go through that as they happen.
So you obviously, you see your demo
being compiled up there. So next time, if
you compile with hyphen t demo, it will
speed up, and we only compile that specific
kind of environment. I think that's
if it takes time here, it's for Docker.
It's not us.
So
if it takes a little bit longer, a
couple of seconds longer, it's just for for
the for the fact that we're using a
Docker image.
K. Now
when
you compile
target,
the output gets producing the compiled folder. So
if you do get this now
or if you go and look at it
through oh, sorry. Get get status so to
to have a look at the files.
You will see that
several files have already been compiled for you.
And the and the the one for your
target will be under the compiled demo.
So
the manifest folder
is the one where we would be interacting
with the most because that's where the generator
places the the files that you are that
you are creating. So if you, you know,
in the editor, open that folder, you will
see already that there is already some magic
happening there, and we can go through
to basically explain a little bit
more what what's happening.
And and yeah. So with the the configuration
you've defined allows us to say
to to to generate the default
object that we use most commonly, which is
the deployment.
So it's just, basically getting rid of all
the boilerplate
and, adding all these kind of a a
kind of a sane initial setup for your,
generator
for your for your deployment
in a way that, you know, you have
something already working out there.
Okay. Can we maybe try and break down
how we got from
from
this
Yeah. To a deployment? How does that generate
or work and interact with what's going on?
So so the the generator is is essentially
a a plug in that we have within
within this repository we have installed here that
basically activates
on whenever you define
this the structure you have here, and then
you can expand it to to add more
value, so to add more components. So every
time you find something other components,
it will basically take that object and try
to do something with it. So, you know,
the I I hate I hope I'm not
getting I'm gonna get, like, a a a
a a CRD.
You define your own CRD of how you
want the deployment to look like. I've used
a very bad example here. But, you know,
it's like you are defining, like, something
that you wanted to turn into a more
complex kind of a a a representation. Presentation.
So in this case, we want to create
a component. We want to call it echo
server, and we want to have that image.
And we can see how we can build
on on that quite quickly.
I think one one more thing we can
say sorry, David. One one more thing we
say is that every
inventory
has the classes and parameters.
So every every file has the cam classes
and parameters keys.
The parameters essentially
feed the input parameters
to a template. And in this case, the
template
is what Ali said as the you know,
it's the what we've brought in
by
cloning the Kapitan reference,
Kapitan templates example. Right? So we already have
a a a baked in template for you
to use.
And that another way you could use this,
you can actually write your own templates, but
for the demo's purpose, we have a baked
in template for you. So that's why there's
a lot of magic happening. So what we've
just done when we've done compile was
we have now created a new directory compiled,
and we've added a new target, which is
a demo target,
with all the files that it generates for
you. And in this case, it generates,
a bunch of Kubernetes manifest files
based on this input from this target.
Okay. Now would it be fair to say
in my naive assumption here that this components
and echo server keys
correlate to this file, that Ginger template file
that we have over here?
That's a coincidence for now. We we will
use it. We will use it. It has
nothing to do with that. So this is
the the bit that is difficult to get.
It's like, with Helm,
just to give an example, with Helm, you
have a value files, and then you have
a a templates that are made of goal
line templates, basically. Right? The text templates.
So you see that kind of a you're
now what you are doing is you are
looking around and you say, Where are where
is where is the the the magician hat?
Where where are the templates are coming from?
Right? What we have effectively is what we
called generator,
which, you were right to to go on
the components.
I think if you go to components,
generators, Kubernetes.
That's it. Don't look into it. Don't open.
No. I mean, it's just
It's just Python
Python
code that basically
using
this software no. I'm kidding. You can open
if you want, but it just
it will it will look nice.
It's basically
Cadet, which is
kind of a our own kind of language
that that
Ricardo
has written that simplifies the generation of manifests
or files or templates in that way. And
so
that kind of generator has been created to
react to the configuration that you define. So
if you write components echo server image, it
will create a deployment with that image.
Okay. Can I test the hypothesis then? What
if I Yes.
Index
image,
NGINX
latest.
And if I what if I just start
going a little bit crazy here?
Okay. You you you need to get the
right setup, but that's the general idea is
correct. You're almost you're close there. So
NGINX,
perfectly fine. Image NGINX,
perfectly fine. Ports, rather than making it a
list, just add the h t t p
under that. So, like, create another key on
the ports,
h t p, and then add the container
port but with the yeah. Okay. Just
okay.
And then container underscore port
because that's how
port a. And
compile away compile away and please make it
crash to to embarrass me and
everybody else. Go for it, and let's see
let's see what happens.
Pace on crash. Pace on crash. There we
crash.
So Anything else? So now so
what do you expect what do you expect
to happen?
I have expect to see an engine x
deployment with this image and the container port
configured with a name and exposing port 80.
Alright. Exactly. You got it there. Yeah. There
you go.
Alright. Let's see. So Okay.
Nice. So now now now you're wondering how
far we can go with this. Right?
Yeah. Okay. I mean, maybe you could help
me understand why,
you know, because this is starting to look
like a pod spec. I know it's not
a pod spec, but this set is probably
gonna be unfamiliar to people coming from Kubernetes.
Mhmm.
So how do how do I learn how
this generator works then? How how do I
know what other keys are available to me?
So if you if you go and look
at the page that you skipped through to
to the
because you you you you are so excited
to to work on this. You you can
basically understand a little bit more about how
it works. And I think the easiest way
is to go through the examples that we
have and we see what we have available.
So
you're right. Obviously,
we've this is a Kubernetes generator.
So
it looks a little bit like a a
pod,
but there is a bit more. So some
of those commands apply to the pod, but
some some of those kind of definition
apply to the pod, some other apply to
configuration file config files or secrets.
I I think
as we go through this, you will you
will understand all the other capabilities. So if
you skip this two kind of main
section, global
general
setup,
and and you go to ports and services.
So here should explain exactly what you were
working on. So you've created, like, a port
setup. So you define
a port with a with a name, so
I should be port. And then you've you
went for container port eighty eighty, which is
intuitively, you got very close to to to
actually the the configuration of of this setup.
And you can basically
it it's a it's a a new format
that you need to learn. So, obviously, you
need to learn how to configure it that
way. But the main advantage you have already
here, and you can see over the other
software, is like
and by
all means, I use Helm as a comparison
just because it's it's
easier to most
people know it. It's like, while with Helm,
you still have to do pretty much the
same job in the values file. Right? Each
values file drives the template in perhaps a
completely different way. Right? So depending on the
template, you will have a different value file
that you need to. Every time you have
a new chart, you need to go through
the values file and understand how to fill
it in to
to to to make it behave the way
you want.
Now, obviously, there are standards and people tend
to use templates in roughly the same way.
So the values
that you define are pretty much always gonna
be the same.
But but that's down to to to to
code in standards. It's not because
Helm enforces you to have a specific structure.
In our case,
those definition, once you learn how to use
it, you can use it to create any
other kind of template you want to create.
So it's a it's a it's a good
to be use of that those configuration right
there.
Yeah. Well, I I love what this one
is doing. So I I need to see
this see this happen.
I mean, this is you know,
nine times out of 10, and that's arbitrary,
but probably a pretty close number. Nine out
of 10 times, what I'm doing with Kubernetes
is deploying a deployment that has a service
that exposes that thing. Right? And Exactly. Exactly.
Exactly. Just template that down to something as
simple as, hey. My Yeah. You know, target
should have these components, and this is how
I tweak them versus Yeah.
Yeah. Fantastic.
At the moment, for for the benefit of
the demo, at the moment, we are doing
everything in the in this target
directory.
You won't find a service there yet. Just
give me a second. I'll recreate the service
as well.
But, like, at the moment, we are doing
everything in the targets file just for other
convenience.
But effectively, you will be moving this kind
of configuration in the more appropriate class later.
But for now, let's let's carry on. So
to have the, if you now scroll down
and you find expose a service,
and then,
there should be a
a
service directory as, directive as well. So okay.
So let,
if you go back to the, target.
Yep. And and let me make sure that
I don't make a mistake there. But if
you write
service,
so you create a new key called service
alongside ports.
Yes?
Yep.
And and then another key type,
and you say cluster
cluster
IP.
Mhmm. Yeah. Now if you compile
so
here,
I think this is the one problem
that we have right now is that probably
possibly we haven't been extremely
I might have made a mistake there. Just
double check with the Thank you. That's okay.
So if you go on Did you create
it? Oh, yeah. Just look at look inside
the bundle. Yeah. Exactly. Yes.
This is one of the thing that annoy
me the most when I start using Kubernetes
is that you have to match the labels
across deployment and service.
And
I was like, you know, it's a beautiful
kind of a a power
ability to decouple the service from from the
Kubernetes. But, you know, how many times do
you actually use it like that? It's like,
it's
just that gets in the way sometimes when
you want to do things your way. Yeah.
So that that's why the default is to
make sure that
the deployment is called echo server, the service
is called echo server, The labels are consistent
across the two,
and and you carry on building the the
service as as you need. If you need
to deviate from it, you can still do
it. But for the time being, this is
an ability to quickly get started with it.
So does that not
have an implicit cluster IP by default?
Would that just now remove that from my
bundle?
It will and now it will remove it.
Yeah.
Right. Okay. Cool. Okay. Thanks.
So
yeah. So I think if you go through
that page, you will be able to see
other examples.
And and I think if you look in
other kind of a components classes,
you can you can understand a little bit
more what you can do. But let's carry
on with what we have here. So if
you go down a little bit let's see
what else. Yeah. Like,
liveness and readiness checks,
you want to add them. So I already
defined the fact that he he can talk
point
to the specific port.
I just hope
I haven't
checked that page in quite a while, so
I'm just hoping that everything works.
In case we can route
immediately to
to an example that is already built for
that. Yeah. There we go. Great. There we
go.
Okay. Now, obviously
ahead, And one thing one thing that we
should mention is that
when I when we briefly mentioned in in
the in the in the slide of the
workflow of Kapitan is that
you are just generating stuff here. And and
the idea of how you should use is
really
you generate
the the compiled files,
and you check them in into your in
your, you know, get whatever.
And then these ones are are deployed as
they are into the cluster. So it becomes
really super easy to know exactly what you
have. Basically, your your your snapshot is your
your your your state is all defined in
Git.
As opposed to, for example, Helm or other
tools,
you don't really it's don't really see by
default what it is actually rendering and applying
to the cluster. We just have that view
of the parameters you you are exposed to
and everything else kind of magic unless you
dig into the code. Our approach is a
bit more verbose,
which might be a bit more overwhelming at
first, but eventually, you have a much clearer
picture of what you're
applying to your cluster.
Excellent.
Okay. So
what should we wanna look at next?
Let's look at config maps. I think that's
where the fun starts from my point of
view. You've not been having fun yet? Come
on.
I should buy stuff. So,
obviously, one of the things they use most
of the time are, like,
again, config maps and secrets. And with the
generators, you basically pretty much define it exactly
the same way. So if you now copy
and paste that into your configuration,
you would see more magic happening,
which is basically
yeah. Add it whatever you want to, whichever
component you you expect it to happen. So
this is just make sure it's indented. Yeah.
It's it's the right indented. Yeah.
So here, I can add
key and secret
value pair, whatever, and that's just gonna work.
Yep. Yep.
So what we tend to do is every
time we make a change, you, like, get
commit so that then you can easily see
the diff, like, of of what you're changing.
Obviously, in this case, it's
you know, we we just playing with it.
As you can see, has generated another
file, NGINX config
with
with that content.
And nice thing is that on top of
the simple value that you can define this
way, this is just to add value to
the Necoserver.
We also suffer support to the the idea
of
connecting
of rendering templates
that come from
an actual Jinja file.
So the one the the the Jinja file
you pointed at before
under the components folder,
that is just a a file that is
there that we can now reuse and see
how it works. So if you if you
remember that you were in the components
folder
and there was a a Ginger file
that you
pointed up before. Yeah. So we could we
could we can now tell the generator that
you want to
use this template in in the in the
compile the in the
example we are doing. So if you copy
that component cycle server if you if you
copy the path to this file,
and then we can define it here,
and you call it another name. So create
that other key. Say saying, like, example.comfour.
If you go one level before.
Yeah. It just inside data.
Exactly. And then add a key called template,
and then you put up path.
And then you add
a
another key.
Oh, wait. I'm lost. So what is m
server config? Yeah.
I mean, this is just a
an example. We have others, but pretty much
any kind and then you have another key
called values,
which is where you basically specify the context.
So in this in this case, if you
write example, which is what the valuable that
that kind of a template is looking for,
Right? Hello.
And, yeah, compile away,
and let's see what happens.
Yep.
Oh,
it didn't crash. Great.
I'm just waiting for that to happen. There
you go. There you go. Yeah. So very
simple,
very quick to get started with it. Now
in the values
kind of key that you defined, you have
access to the full feature of the inventory,
which is
variable interpolation.
So you can now take a value from
anywhere else in the inventory
and
And then something like a target name,
just to make it easy.
What we are saying here is we are
telling Kapitan or we're telling the inventory
to replace that value with the inventory value
called target
name, which can be defined in any other
class as long as it's within the inventory.
So this is very powerful because allows you
to basically refer to to other kind of
values that you have configured somewhere else.
So now, again, if you compile, you will
see the expected change,
Hopefully.
So far
okay. For this demo.
Yeah. It it can be much more complex.
So if you look at the
com the example for
component sorry. Inventory classes components,
my SQL,
likely, I added it, right, yesterday,
a bit more of so inventory,
classes, components,
MySQL.
So this is obviously
a little bit more of a complicated setup.
If you want, we can look at it
later. But pretty much, you can see other
kind of configuration,
and you can see that the templates here
reads
the the the settings
block that you see up there. So we
are referring
to another kind of a part of the
inventory configuration,
allows you to easily
play and and and change with these parameters
as you create different components of MySQL across
all the different components.
So I think one one thing we can
also look at is something we we already
mentioned before is, if you go back in
the terminal, David,
you can type
Kapitan inventory
dash t demo
dash uppercase f.
Yeah. So it flattens out inventory, and it
renders the inventory.
So now you will see everything rendered for
you.
And,
for example,
you can grep for
target name.
Well, there you go. Right? So
this is that this is just a simple
example of how you can visualize
the inventory
rendered
and how you can actually use other
validating the inventory in your templates or within
your classes,
whatever.
K?
Nice.
Alright. We have a question,
which may be quite tricky, but I'm gonna
give you it anyway. So Yeah.
Sharath is asking, is it possible to give
Kapitan knowledge of what Kubernetes version is the
target so that I can adjust the API
version and kind appropriately
if needed?
Yeah. So
at the current generator, it doesn't do that,
but we are planning on on on allowing
it. At the moment, we are you know,
this generator is something that
it was originally
originally
generated created a a synthase, which is the
company that
where I'm working.
And I've then converted into cadet.
We are adding more and more features, one
of which is adding schemas
and add adding the ability to also target
a specific Kubernetes version. So at the moment,
it's not possible. So we tend to default
to the latest version available,
but we see that that's something that is
needed. And effectively,
it wouldn't be more difficult than just defining
somewhere,
you know,
an inventory value that points to
the Kubernetes
setup that you have, and then from that,
it will understand
what version to use. So not possible at
the moment, but definitely something feasible.
And if I might if I might
reiterate a little bit,
not possible generators.
If you use plain Kapitan,
you're completely
free to do
this feature yourself,
if that helps. Yeah.
So
the this is an important thing. So if
people have experience with Kapitan before,
before the
path to do what you've done now was
to create, like, a JSON or a cadet
file for each component, and then every time
you had to repeat pretty much the same
stuff. So you could reuse some some things.
Like, in in this way, we realized that
pretty much all like, in our situation,
my company, we have, like, microservices
all configured the same way, but with a
couple of variations.
And I just got tired of dealing with
all those different kind of variation across TAM.
So I say, I think there must be
a better way, which is what led us
to to use the to to this approach.
Do you want
yeah. Do you want to
continue with more fun? I think we have
a couple more
things that might be of interest.
So first of all, the same setup you
see now with the config maps. If you
even just create
instead of config map, you create the same
setup with written
secrets, it will work exactly the same. So
interface for for both of them is the
same. And you can do all the things
that you're expecting
out of the same setup. So you can
mount
the config map
into the pod you defined like that. Yeah.
Oh, that's the minus go on. We can
close that.
So here, I can just say that I
actually want to maintenance.
Yes. Under that directory.
And yeah.
And then we do all the conf needed
configuration for it.
And if I pop open our bundle again,
we should see
we
have our volume and configured
Yeah. And our volumes here. Very cool. Yeah.
Now
the
standard
setup that we have is that every time
you create, like, a a configuration
config map,
it's named after the component you define. So
if you have only one config map, it's
named after the same component. Obviously, this is
doesn't work if you if you, for any
reason, you need more than one config map
defined.
In that case, the name morphs to be
component name and then the config map name
so that you can have a you know,
the the the default is to make sure
that it's as
as easy as possible to refer to to
to to that specific config map.
Yeah. So
we can
also
I don't know if we have all the
the the explanation here, but you can also
mount only specific files. So you can also
just
yeah. You can also do the sub path
bound. So you can say, I want to
just mount this specific file under this directory.
Not sure if I if we have to
come into the all of it, but
it's it's all possible, and it's it's something
that in
any case can be improved
very quickly.
Alright. Oh, yes. There it goes. Filtering files
to mount. There we go. Look at that.
Oh, yeah. So we can use an ATOM.
There we go. Yeah.
And secrets are pretty much just the same
thing. Right? Yeah. The secret the only difference
is that you also have the ability to
base 64 encode it. So if you create,
like, a simple
if you create a simple
value
and you want the base 64 encode it,
it it does it for you. Right? That's
the only difference with the config map, really.
K. And we have the ability to hook
into various cloud KMS systems or local GPG
in order to actually store and encrypt those
secrets at a safe in Opsi fashion?
Yes. And or the best of them all,
base 64, the most secure them all. This
setup.
Yeah. I don't even just I just string
the key and just YOLO it all the
way. So Yeah. So so, like, you won't
be able to use this example right away
now. But if we just accept
the fact that we are in a demo
and we are all friends,
and and if you change the if you
copy this and you change g k m
s with you you replace with plain,
so under under the oh, yes. That's perfect.
Yeah.
Yeah. Just change it to plain. So let's
pretend we are on a a safe network
and a
safe Internet.
This is I think if you
compile,
I think it gives you a very good
idea
of of what happens.
So
the import so this is basic Safari encoded.
So,
you know, you have to,
yeah, decode that. That's true.
But, basically, the the,
important,
feature that I would like to point out
is that,
Kapitan's
when they are generating a secret, Kapitan has
a number of functions that you can use
to bootstrap the value of the of that
secret. So you can automatically generate a random
string, automatically generate,
like, an error say key
and the and the relative kind of public
keys, and and we can add more and
more function as we go. And I think
this is what we call, like, declarative secrets
in a way with a very fancy name
because what we want to do is capture
not only the fact that you have a
secret, but also how you generated it.
And I think that's quite important. I think
it's a it's it's a nice
approach that
we we tend to use and we tend
to
tell people to, you know, to go for.
I think one cool detail is that if
you go back to to your previous file
and you change plain to
base 64 and then you compile again,
you will see something a bit different.
Right.
So that is what we call the reference.
And if you check the
Kapitan. Dev documentation,
it actually calls that a reference, and which
means that that it actually points to
the state
that is saved,
you know, directly called refs in your repository,
which means that the next time you compile
the same thing,
the reference to that compiled state is reused.
So, for example, if we were to use
real encryption, not base 64, it's not encryption.
For example, a GPG or GKMS,
you are the developer. You are deciding what
the secret is like. You commit that.
The second developer does not necessarily need to
have access to your the same secrets,
but he can still
recompile stuff and have the same results. Right?
Decrypting is a different story, but that's the
idea.
Yeah. And so when you apply, you have
to reveal the file, by the way.
And and if you look at now at
your directory, there will be other files being
created under the refs
directory,
and those are the one that I think
Ricardo Ricardo
is referring to that hold the information about
the password.
So in in this case, we are basically
generating the password, writing into this reference file
that you check-in.
Obviously,
not the basic c four one, but the
when you use a a a real back
end, like a secret back end, you can
securely
store with you the encrypted version of that
password,
and you can share it around only at
the act of revealing.
So only only when you need to apply
that configuration to the cluster, only then you
need the the permission to read that secret.
So all your other colleagues can be using
Kapitan
without having to need access to these secrets,
which is already, for instance, a difference with
I must say, I don't use other tools,
obviously.
But, like, if you use GitCrypt or if
you use other alternatives,
I think, much you need to set up
your environment to be able to read those
secrets even if you are not the person
that is meant to consume those those secrets.
In this case, we there is a nice
properties, the fact that you only need to
reveal these
secrets
when you are applying
this kind of configuration to the cluster,
which is something that we can also delegate
to another project we have, which is Tesoro,
which is basically a tool that runs in
the cluster.
It's the only one that needs to be
able how to decipher the secrets, and then
everybody else can be locked out of of
understanding, you know, even understanding what the secrets
is about.
Very
powerful secret management there, I think. Lots of
flexibility
to
and then just being able to hook into
those cloud KMSs, I think that's important. We
shouldn't be using I would argue we shouldn't
be using local GPG or shipping around private
keys and things like that. You know, that's
how excels there. This is this is something
I'm I'm trying to get people to understand
is that even if you have your own
kind of bare metal installation of Kubernetes,
you can still use, like,
KMS from Google or KMS from AWS
to you know, you you can use just
those tools, and they are so cheap to
use. They doesn't even make sense unless you
have a specific need.
Bringing up the whole vault setup just to
make sure that you have the, you know,
this couple capabilities, it doesn't make sense to
us. So that's why g k m s
is standing over the AWS version of the
Azure version if you really,
you know, fancy
trying all the different clouds.
They are they are available for you through
Kapitan built in, and you can just, you
know, get going very quickly.
Yeah. I often work with bare metal Kubernetes
environments as I think you may be aware,
and I often use GKMS
pretty much. So it's just yeah. You're right.
It's almost free to a certain point depending
on how much you need to access it.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Alright. Let's show off some more cool stuff
before we finish off then.
And if you wanna lead us towards
I I think I
think this is something that I think you
got to the other nice section I would
have wanted to explore.
The fact that so far we defined basically
things that are related to the deployment, the
secrets, and coughing maps, you know, the the
typical stuff that you normally expect to to
have it on deployment.
But sometimes there are kind of other
features that you want to other kind of
characteristic you want to build into your deployments,
which would normally require you to have a
specific template just to deal with that. So
the generator takes care of that. So, like,
in the case of network policies,
if you define the network policy kind of
block, you will create a network policy for
you.
Prometheus rules,
if you define
the
this kind of a setup, it will basically
automatically create all the Prometheus kind of configuration
that you all the kind of related to.
This is the example where you're using the
parameters operator.
And the same if you go down, there
is another service
service monitor.
So now if you cut and paste this
into your configuration,
you you basically
by adding a little bit of a of
a of an extra configuration bit, you you
you can generate many other associated
ancillary
kind of resources
that logically belong to that application.
So within the same application, you can define
many other kind of behaviors
without having to deal with a specific template
for creating service monitoring
and network policy.
And and
also
while with the other tooling, again, because they
they require you to have the templating
specific for the feature you want to enable.
So in if you are unlucky enough to
use a,
like, perhaps
a a chart that hasn't been looked after
properly and probably doesn't have the service manager
configuration,
I think you need to add it yourself.
I don't use it, but my the my
understanding is that you need to go and
add the template to that chart and make
sure they work for you. But if you
go down the generator route, you can basically
every feature we add to the generator can
be can be used by any,
component you define.
So is that to say that I could
have Kapitan
reference a helm chart that I'm still using,
but I wanna enrich with new manifests and
Kapitan can
generate or compel them into it for me.
So that's what we we would be working
on. It's not possible yet. What I meant
is that
both the echo server and the NGINX that
you defined can both benefit from these kind
of features,
which is something that, you know, like, you
can have, like, 20 components
and easily
add to all of them consistently
the same configuration, the serve same service monitor
configuration,
and the the same kind of network policy
policy, like, consistently across all of them. So
I'm I'm just saying that even if there
is a feature missing of the generator, the
moment in which we add the feature to
the generator,
it automatically
it's automatically available
to all the
manifest
all the definition you've created of all the
components.
I don't know if you if that was
clear, if you feel like
if
I can explain if I if I need
to to to repeat that again. But I
think I find it interesting that
we can easily add more and more
magic kind of a generator
kind of a a incantation.
And the moment in which we add it
to the to the and we publish that
kind of a a feature,
it's available to all your
components that you've defined through Kapitan.
It's very easy to to deploy a feature
across all of them.
That makes sense. Awesome.
Okay.
What
next?
I think I just ended the reference. Right?
We kinda covered the generators,
how they work, what they do, what's coming.
I mean, you've covered quite a lot there.
Is there I think
think we can pass some of the stuff
he places into the target into a a
class. So just to make a target a
bit neater.
Right?
Okay. Yes. So
to be honest, you can also
yeah. Or you use a class that we
have there. So if you want, you can
so the echo server is sending with the
final ready. So if instead of defining your
own version,
you you load the class called
so if you yeah. If you in the
classes section,
if you load the class called components
echo server,
yep,
which has already, like,
lots of configuration
defined, which are beyond the the what you
had before.
So if you just load that class, it
will basically inherit all these features automatically. It's
it's like an example class that we have
there.
And at the same time, if you want,
you can install
MySQL by just simply adding
component
components MySQL to the classes section up there.
And so we could in theory, I mean,
we could just remove all of this and
use those classes that were provided. Right? So
that would be And
I think this is good because we can
show you how you can override the content
of those classes, which is something that until
now we didn't need to because we were
doing it, by the way.
Yeah.
We could do that. Right? That's I think
that's okay. Yep. That's fine.
Then we can recompile, and we'll end up
in a pretty similar place. It said, now
we're gonna have an added MySQL bundle and
a modified echo server. So Yes. See.
So, yep, we've got our Mhmm.
Yeah. Table set for MySQL.
And where is our echo server?
Very, similar. Nice. Yes. And
if you look at the echo server class
now, the
inventory classes component
echo server,
you basically it's it's a you know, it's
a it's probably the most complete example that
we have. So that everything you can think
of has been added to this class. So
but we can see that another kind of
you know, you have network policies defined. You
have a a side container as well, you
know, additional containers. So you have a side
container with NGINX, which is also nice. And
you could see that pretty much the the
configuration is pretty much the same.
So pick something that you want to override,
and we can override it on the at
the parameter level.
Yeah. So this is
Alright. And something that may be common then,
like, if I were to take if I
wanted to deploy this echo server across multiple
environments from staging to production, then the probes
may change slightly. Like, I mean, in production,
be a little bit more hesitant with or
a bit more aggressive with the time out,
whereas in staging, I make it a bit
longer.
Exactly. Exactly. So we can do that. Right?
So in the target, because it's a demo
environment, perhaps we the time out of what
we want it to be, instead of three
seconds, we can we can it can be,
like, I don't know, eight
10.
Yeah. Ten seconds. I know. Yeah. So the
the way it works is that you can
now in the demo target,
you basically recreate
the
the YAML structure up until the parameter
you want to change. So it will be
components,
echo server,
liveness check,
I think it was called.
Will underscore.
I think it
yeah. And then time out.
Yeah. Just make sure I was just checking.
Yeah. Excellent.
And then we
can turn to
health check
liveness time out seconds. There you go.
Health check.
I'm at
I can't
Yep. And
What we should see when you tile this
in is that our echo server bundle, we're
gonna have this time out
of the liveness probe,
which is here.
We should see lane 40 changed at ten.
Yeah.
Which is where committing it to get, you
know, like,
helps in this case because you can see
easily see the diffs between them.
There you go. Has it changed? Yeah. Changed.
Gotcha.
Now now this is now
this is an important thing that I think
you can go back to something I said
before. If you go back to the target,
what you've done here is to add a
time out seconds. But the reason why you
wanted to add the time out second is
because you said it's different environment type.
So if instead of doing it this way,
you you create a class called,
like, a a subdirectory called profiles,
and then you say, I don't know, testing
or them demo or
low latency or Whatever.
Whatever you want to call it. You can
then copy this configuration that now doesn't make
sense. In a in three months time, you
won't remember what this is about. Right? But
you can add it under something called profiles,
you know,
testing
yeah. Testing. Well, you know, you you come
up with a word that you you like.
So we have a new class?
Yes. It can. There's a new class called
whatever you want. Like, I think staging and
oh, yeah. Like, environment staging.
Let's call it forgiving. Let's use the forgiving.
Yep. Forgiving is good.
And then we call this whatever we want.
So let's just see.
Main dot YAML.
Yeah. We that's okay. Sorry. Something we need
to work on.
Yeah.
And
then from here,
I could just augment this with my forgiving
Main. Main.
Yeah.
Forgiving.
Now you you managed to turn into something
even more difficult to understand what he was
referring to. But
but
but you you you get you get my
point. Right?
Well, I think what I'm in my head,
what I was thinking is, you know, there
are certain constraints that I wanna apply to
different environments. And I'll forget it was a
terrible name, but, you know, I'm gonna be
running maybe consistent performance performance testing on this
environment. I'm using debugging tools enabled. So things
will generally be slower. Yeah. We have Exactly.
Chaos being artificially injecting time out, whatever. So
being able to group these together as a
a component that is reusable
to apply to the target environment as kinda
what I was going for there. But yeah.
Maybe Exactly.
And and I think something else you can
do just because we are we are playing
with the with the organizing it better. In
the forgiving main or even in the echo
server setup, instead of defining
the time out like this, you can actually
define a time out seconds on on the
on the under parameters.
Exactly. You're already there. Yeah.
So this means that
now
and and if especially if you apply to
other components,
it it define it means that you can
define that across
all the components that you have around your
you know, all the components you are deploying,
you make sure that you consistently apply to
all all the different kind of deployments you
have.
And, also, you can go ahead and and
duplicate that targets and call it prods and
then change the value. And now you have
two very similar targets.
With Yeah. No. I've got no no. My
forgiving name is getting worse and worse as
we change the name. Right? But Hey. The
the name should be something that makes sense
for you. If it makes sense for you,
then we're good. Right?
Yeah. You're right. Okay. So and then, like
you said, we can say, hey, Rawkode. We're
gonna have a slightly different performance
testing one. So hold on. Wrong. Yeah. No.
That's the right directory. Okay.
Performance.YAML.
And, actually, we we really wanna test this,
and we're gonna go with with a one.
So now that's these are factored, but we
that's not today's lesson. So
Yeah. So,
basically I think this is Sorry, Nico. I
was on the No. No. Go. Go. Go.
Go. Go. Please. I I just, you know,
I I I love confirming why I really
work I enjoy working with a tool, and
it's just this composability. The way that we're
moving things around and grouping things into use
cases and behaviors that we wanted and augment
into our targets. I think this is really,
really powerful.
There are some some aspects of it that
you will become even more clear as you
use it. And it's something that I had
a colleague of mine that used it for
several kind of weeks, and then he did,
a a refactoring
of the inventory to, you know, to shuffling
things around. And he compiled,
and he didn't see any change in the
compiled folder. It was like, oh, something is
broken. Something is not working. But that's exactly
the beauty of adding the compiled
files together with the template is that you
can refactor
the inventory or the templates as much as
you want.
But if you don't change the kind of
a functional behavior of what you're doing,
you have a immediate guarantee that whatever you've
done hasn't disrupted your your workflow.
So now you can you can move things
around and it it doesn't
change.
Yeah. Kinda like TDD for your manifest. When
you're refactoring, you wanna make sure all your
tests pass here. You'd wanna make sure your
output doesn't change. So Yeah. So what what
we
Actually, you can actually
you write can write test for you. Right?
You can write test to validate
your YAML. So you it is it's gonna
be up to you. Yeah. I can imagine
once you do the compilation step, being able
to run some sort of over rego against
it to, you know Yeah. Make sure that
it conforms to all the rules that we
have in place for those environments, which we're
really careful as well. Yep. Yeah. So before
we had a JSONET based generator.
So when I wrote the cadet based one,
the Python one,
the only thing that changed was the speed
of compiling.
Other than that, it was pretty much it
produced no output, which gave me the immediate
guarantee that whatever I had done, I was
able, with the cadet version, to basically recreate
exactly the same behavior in the JSONX version.
And and and so you you have an
immediate reassurance that what you've done hasn't impacted
any any component.
Yeah. Excellent.
Is there anything else that you would like
to cover before we finish up for today?
What's your favorite feature? Have we touched on
it? Have we done it? Have we shown
it? We've we've touched on a lot of
stuff.
I know that it's
potentially gonna be a demo. Did we cover
everything that's in your demo, or would you
like to go ahead with that?
Yeah. Pretty much, basically, the only thing I
was going to do is, like, through go
through exactly the same.
And and,
you know,
I think we've covered everything. I think another
bit that we can show
actually, we can even tell without even having
to to go through the pain of of
recompiling. But
you can add if you want to have
virtual pod auto scaling, you know, just do
VPA
auto. Boom. It works. If you want to
have a a pod disruption policy,
you just have to define pod structure policy
and it works. So it's all kind of
a small other kind of features that you
can we can add and we add it
to the generators
so that you can
easily
take advantage of a of a of a
other
kind of
Kubernetes features that otherwise would would have to
be maintained manually.
Yeah. Think it's called auto,
uppercase uppercase
auto.
That's it. Yeah. I'm not gonna that's an
opportunity here to see if I can add
a BPA to this. So you know? I
guess another thing we can do is just
really show the scripts, which is
probably a controversial
feature,
but you can actually generate executable
scripts,
which we already did.
There you go. Added it? Yeah. Got it.
Yeah. Oh, it's I went too far down.
There we go. There we There we go.
DPA. Yeah. Nice.
Yeah.
So
if you if you now open the another
target file
so for instance, the tutorial one,
it should be one called tutorial.
Yes.
So in the top part, you see that
project to local host Kubernetes kind.
If you copy and paste that into your
configuration,
into your
target file
yeah.
So
and compile.
What we are doing here is that we
are and you can open that class to
see basically what it has. We're basically
you'll see here a change in the scripts
file, which is actually was already there. Mhmm.
What you see now is that we've basically
imported information about a specific Kubernetes. As you
can imagine, it's called KIND in this case.
And do you have KIND installed in your
machine just to prevent
actually, open setup cluster.
Yeah?
I I do have KIND available. Yes. Great.
Yeah. So now if you run on the
terminal,
compiled
just execute it right from where you are.
So compile.
Demo scripts. Demo scripts cluster.
Yeah. Go for it. Let's see if it
works. I mean, this is a
I think
The demo gods, man. So far, they've been
with us.
Demo. We haven't we haven't broken a single
compile. I mean, we just have to, like,
break it on purpose. This is insane.
This is live typing. I promise.
And I I think the time it takes
for here to set up to remind everybody
listening
on the stream to retweet and talk about
Kapitan and and sponsor us if you can.
And file bugs. Basically, we we are,
yeah, and and the file, all the bugs
you find. But we are going to spend
much more time to make it working this
year. So
I think we are on a on a
good path. I think we have a good
idea, and it would be nice to see
more people
taking advantage of it.
I guess adding new
automations to the generators could be a really
good way for people to contribute, adding new
keys that Yeah. Get expanded into behaviors that
they wanna see,
you know Exactly. Trivialized.
So the the beauty of the generator is
that, for instance, we can create now a
spinnaker generator.
For instance, for in my case, we use
spinnaker at work. The spinnaker generator can
see the compiled
echo server. They compile the
deployment you've created. And based on that, you
can create a pipeline to deploy those kind
of configurations.
So and then if you have a secret,
you will automatically
instruct Spinnaker,
then now there is a new manifest to
be deployed.
So, actually, by using the same kind of
configuration,
multiple
generator can provide a different behavior. So if
you add an Argo CD generator, you will
create all the Arco CD configuration
that you need to to deploy your configure.
So I think the generator pattern is something
as trivial to add, and it will give
a lot of benefit to the people using
Kapitan.
So now if you do and run compile
demo scripts setup
context
and you actually don't even need to run
this because it it's automatically when you run
cube control, but yeah.
And then you run
cube cube control
get bugs.
Get bugs.
I mean, there's nothing now, but Yeah. And
then if you
instead of instead
of cube control
dot s h, you run apply dot s
h.
Yeah.
And the here, we actually see if if
they we've generated
a rubbish or or if they actually yeah.
Here we go. Yeah. Our secret. Okay.
No. I see. It's a secret. Yeah. Exactly.
And the vertical
pod autoscaler, I think it's a different version
just to
need to update that. I
think you already I don't know what that
question we had earlier. Exactly.
Yeah. I was just
going to reply to. It's very relevant to
that comment.
But, basically, the the point is here, if
we just take away the the good part
of it, not the fact that it crashed,
is that
it enables you to create scripts that are
already
configured to operate with a specific
deployment.
So it doesn't matter on which context your
machine is is funding at. You can you
know that you can run get pods under
using the script to to point to exactly
the version that you're you're
you want to have
you want to be working with.
So the same thing is that if you
now go compiled
tutorial
scripts
apply
right away so we we try this and
probably we fail for the same reason, but
it basically will
recreate the context
and and deploy these
values
without you having to do anything with it.
If you do yeah.
So this this this is a very a
very powerful obstruction. I mean, for people who
work with Kubernetes every day, fine. It's perfectly
obvious. But we had,
you know, people who were not so familiar
with it, and they've got extremely confused with
the difference between namespaces and context and clusters.
So the idea is that we we can
actually template all of this in the script
that is runnable, and the script is basically
omnipresent.
Right? If you run that, it just works
for that particular setting. It doesn't work for
anything else. So you you basically end up
running
the scripts for the target you I think
you're
think you're breaking up, Ricardo. Don't know if
it's just me. No. Was okay on my
side, I think.
Okay. So it's it's just me then.
I I know about all that stuff, so
it's fine.
Alright. Excellent. Yep.
Do want to show anything else? Last chance.
Good. I think the only other other example
that I would like to show is
if you look at so you open briefly
the
we works
class.
Uh-huh. Yep. So if you go inventory
classes.
It was there.
I have the feeling I have a
yeah. Inventory,
classes.
Yeah.
Ah, there we go.
Components.
Yeah. Workshop.
So now
here here, basically, I have replicated
all the configuration
for the WeWorks
soft shop example that they have on on
the repo.
I was looking for something with enough kind
of
a complicated kind of setup just to to
prove the point that manifests work nicely. If
you open any of these files, you can
pretty much see the configuration of how to
recreate that kind of a specific
component.
The
information the bit I wanted to
talk about is this application sock shop that
is a way to basically
define a common
variables that you want to apply to all
these components at once. So now if you
go in the inventory
inventory
classes, applications shop that you see right there
Sorry. Application stock shop. Yep.
Yep. That that's the one. Yep. So
you can see that from this kind of
application, we've obviously called in all the different
components,
but we also some define some default
behavior at the end. If you go scroll
to the bottom. So we define some
defaults
that we want to apply to all those
components that match the same application class at
once, which is yet another way to define
kind of a a characteristic
that you want to to be applied to
all your components at once that you're generating.
So in the case that you went before
for changing
the time out,
if you change the time out with this
kind of a
if you basically make your comp all your
component
belongs to an application
or even if you just change the generator
default
time out version,
you can then apply that time out to
all your components at once without having to
go through echo server, MySQL, NGINX, and so
on. So I think that's another important aspect.
The fact that the generator has different level
of in of of kind of defaults,
you can override that as well.
Excellent.
Alright. And I think that's it for me.
Yeah. We we covered an awful lot actually
there. I'm really happy with how much we've
gotten through there, and we never broke up
never broke a single compile. So that was
pretty successful, I'll say.
I wanted to say thank you both for
you for joining me today. You know, I
think it was really good to go through
Kapitan from start to finish. You know, I
think we covered all of the major vocabulary
that people need to be familiar with. You
know, we broke down the generators and and
what they're useful for and how they work
and just really showed a really great way
for interacting and working with Kubernetes customers. So,
again, thank you both for joining me, and
that was really good fun.
Anything you want to say before we finish
up? I know that you want to encourage
contributions.
So, you know, the repository is at github.com
slash someone help me out there.
Yeah. Sure. So so
You, me? Me? You gotta find something. Maintain
it.
It.
Yeah. Good luck on it out there, Alessandro.
So I'll let Ricardo
give some details there. Yeah. Sure. So, yeah,
if you wanna contribute and you shared, there's
no reason why I shouldn't,
you can go to github.com/kapitan.
Kapitan with a k, just like Kapitan.
As many bugs, as many ideas. There's a
lot of people actually helping out in this
really fun community.
We're also on Slack, the Kubernetes Slack under,
hashtag Kapitan.
Oh, crap. I don't think I'm in there.
I'm gonna have to get in there. Alright.
Mhmm. Alright. Again, thank you very much. That
was that was great. Really great project. Everyone
should definitely check it out, I think, to
get a lot of value from adopting Kapitan.
Have a great day. I'll speak to you
both soon. Thank you.
Thanks. Thank you, David. Take care.